welcome to this video round nine the
final round for the Tom memoria 2013 it
had it has been really a ruler coast of
tournament where Nakamura for no one
looked like um yes I'm going doing to
get his some one of the best results of
his career and then he lost two games
against first against gelfand and then
against Oh Carlton and yeah no no
cameras down to +1 and girl font is
looking like the most likely tunneled
when I with plus free going into this
final round and Carson is just half a
point behind but we get to this some
near the end of the video let's look so
at some other games first we start with
corona against a draicon um yeah corona
is having a decent tournament and if he
is going to win this game or if he would
put in this game I understand that he's
getting above 2800 if I'm mistaken
somebody wrote that yesterday and some
forum I didn't really check that but if
not he's very close I mean he's 27 74
here in num in the text the only SEC and
I know he gains some points in the Grand
Prix and even here so he's brought
number three at the moment so the wind
for Carolyn I would net him to wait
probably and that record is playing an
excellent tournament he beat Kramnik and
didn't lose a game so being the raging
underdog um this is excellent so we have
a rule and unmaking playing the deferred
or sometimes called improved steinitz
with v6 this is in fact a line that is
very interesting for black if you want
to play something slightly out of the
ordinary the point of this move oddest
despite
instead of nine f6 and Bishop e7 that
you have some flexibility in regards to
your king side sometimes you can even
play f5 like in this this line of the
so-called siesta variation not quite
sure why does khan siesta variation but
it's quite interesting and okay for
black and black oftentimes managers to
play g6 and set of Bishop e7 and we see
that in the game c3 should be seven
castles g6t for and Bishop g7 I just
understood just saw that F didn't have
dotted any sound I like this little
clicks Bishop g7 so black fianchetto the
bishop age three are the normal Remos
removes Knight f6 Ruby one castles 92
all very standard looking but in
contrast to some other rule of pest
lines black has this fianchetto and
quite often the bishop is not bad on g7
rook e8 bishop c2 yeah and now it's
interesting black hair certainly has
more than one valid set up one thing he
needs to address is this piece the
knight on c6 it's um it's not very well
placed here because those squares are
controlled by white porn on c3 and you'd
like to improve the service piece and
use the C porn somehow what I reckon is
doing is quite a good maneuver now is
playing Quint here not have one and
queen to f8 so the queen is out of the
way and maybe black can't even manage to
play rook da to bishop CA d5 something
like that play in the center and also
there is Bishop h6 the right moment it's
not so easy for right now to make any
progress without playing d5 and in fact
kawana play to d5 just now right before
black could go for the 65 themselves
so we get this closed position that is a
bit similar to the Kings Indian the only
differences and a couple of because of
the piece placement but it's the same
structure White has saponin c3 but it's
it's a very similar structure not h2 and
Bishop age six this is one good point of
the Queen f8 maneuver this bad bishop is
exchanged and now the Queen occupies
this good spot yeah in fact I I like a
black strategy it looks some looks fine
to me probably the position is only very
slightly better for white due to the
space advantage but it's nothing too
serious black has ideas like a five of
course and something that you played in
the game not age five this is quite
interesting I think I know like 50 years
ago if this kind of move would have been
yeah revolutionary to allow your pawn
structure to be shattered but ever since
Fisher allows the same thing against
Spassky in Reykjavik 72 this is nothing
special anymore today f5 black gets the
Jeep audigy file and this points okay
they are not pretty but how does white
win them it's not clear how to do that
this simply make sure that black has
counter play and it also opens up we see
later black played at five we see later
that black has this idea getting rid of
the Jeep on transferring it to age five
opening the position up gives black
definite counter play with open lines
and the problem is that white doesn't
really have a useful porn break he would
like to place he 45 the C file but this
is all terribly slow so why it needs to
be rather models TM there is some not
much that you can do corona is just
defending here defending this defending
and with look I mean so that black
cannot check the exchange or something
and then it's but it's not a big problem
white with some some good moves keep
some the position equal white really
doesn't have much in terms of active
play we can just make sure as mentioned
that nothing terrible happens Black has
got some activity but I did to edit some
checks also with the comp um it never
gave like anything substantial
especially after the night has been
routed to e-form obviously a nice post
but them white is in no position to
really play for for win here yeah this
is another idea getting the night on
this nice post age six was hanging
otherwise this would be nice but this is
hey so Queen here rookie form and here
the game was in fact drawn so I'm a good
result for Andre can +1 and Cara wanna
okay he probably isn't I'm terribly
excited about his tournament but it was
very solid 94 is the move you kind of
expect but white can always check the
exchange a few wants or play kings to
this exchange sec let's say it's
something like this it's always
interesting for white with this kind of
idea coming or you can simply ignore it
I mean to be honest you shouldn't black
play on here with 94 I didn't analyze
this so much really but he could have
done bad after Luke takes before I don't
think black is risking much
but maybe white can just ignore the
night can you ignore it something like
that now it's not so clear what black is
actually doing here can you can put it
here but what are you threatening this
is not not possible yeah I guess a
choice is not to half pretty logical
result okay um kayaking island next I'm
not also having a rotten tournament he's
got black now and playing the night off
and kayaking plays Bishop g5 the the
traditional sharp main line of the night
off where I am why does trying sort of
serve and volley approach and Queen B 6
is the infamous poisoned pawn Queen d2
queen bee 222 queen bee to be one Queen
a 3 this is some the main line position
here of course this opening has been a
favorite of fishes from back in the 60s
and then Kasparov was the main
practitioner not not only of the night
up a lots of Queen B 6 he had good
results with that all the time but
Kasparov phone didn't face Bishop g5
song and people simply didn't dare to do
that on some occasions they played it to
to make a draw because here there are
some lines that are for straws but again
this is not an issue here kayaking
playing he 5s move had been forgotten
for for ages and then it was on earth to
a couple of years ago h6 Bishop H for
the
is inserted and now black takes after
recapture the traditional main move he
always has been night after this heaven
after which i'm not mistaken White has
most others tried to move Bishop b5 this
is the position there there are similar
positions the compass actually telling
me it's not working why not sure Quincy
five okay I see yeah well there are many
crazy complications I'm probably
screwing some news on up here in any
case Allen played 95 which is a recent
development this move was virtually
unknown couple of years ago takes and he
sticks it it's looking really dangerous
for black I mean he's got no pieces out
but the issue is not so much that black
is some porn up but also that from a
structural point of view why this very
bad shape this is very weak this poem is
weak I mean okay it's getting lost or
traded now but he's got lots of
structural weaknesses and black survives
this this attack he suddenly is in fine
shape Allen took this and here i only
have found moves with Knight takes c6
this has been been played before you go
to play yeah this is heather's has been
played before takes takes Bishop to d3
you should be seven and Bishop g6 check
this has been played before and more
than one game actually and it very often
ended in a draw like some perpetual or
very sharp sequence where some
repetition was necessary but here
kayaking plays differently I'm not sure
if it's a nullity because um
I don't have all the latest games in my
database I've got most but not not so
confident to say that this is a novelty
took on b7 just not revolutionary move
by the difference is after you should be
six and they exchange the differences
that black he actually has the
opportunity to castle and the other line
this wasn't possible important is of
course that white cannot take this you
cannot take here because there should be
four wins the Queen so why play Bishop
to e2 amongst others this idea and he's
not going to d3 because after castles he
intended Queen D for this was played and
now who gave Sam which is necessary this
made threat was very dangerous so it
took and castles will check so it's
clear that white has got some attack I
mean he's got this as a target but black
can secure the pawn with the check yet
now some repetition and now white
avoided okay now he just gives away the
h-bomb but it's a it's a concrete line
this made threat is so strong black
needs to get the Queen's a few plays
Queenie for check its traded and Bishop
g4 so e six is attacked and there's also
if black would do this there's this
coming
so black yet still give it up jack yeah
it was 22 pieces saying so we saw this
yeah and after Luke takes you to very
shortly afterwards they agree to draw
yeah exactly here yeah this is
completely dead yeah I guess I'm a very
theoretical game this happens in those
very sharp lines of the night off they
both have their prep and if it if it's a
draw it can happen that they both just
play their preparation it's also
possible that one of them had some idea
and at the board and didn't really
couldn't make it work and yeah I
couldn't make it work and then had to go
to the draw it's not always the case
that when what you and sometimes here
where they don't fight whatever it's a
sharp line but sometimes it happens
simply that the the draw is some the
logical result of the game so next game
let's go to Nakamura against normal
savage so knock I really on the down
yeah put it down I guess after the two
losses it's now a chance to maybe do
something against Morrow who's neither
the bottom of the table yeah Bishop g5
this is somewhat unusual move here one
idea is that after this sorry after this
black has this move or the smooth or
this one so some specific lines after we
should revive there are slight
differences for example c5 isn't such a
great move here because what nor can
transpose into proper tarish there is
not something like this or 95 and it's
not a good form of the tower
so black usually replies here Bishop e7
going to the classical Queens gambit all
place this age six is another move okay
but here what what about this position
here Knight c3 transposes back into the
regular Queens gambit Rogozin variation
but the camera at the different idea to
take Knight B to D 2 and this is in fact
um interesting but also slightly risky
um yeah morale has got nothing to lose
he grabs the pawn it's also probably the
best move take the pawn while you have
the chance III it be five to protect
them upon yet black is really defending
the pawn it's possible here one issue
for right of course is that in this
gambit style position the night on d2
isn't such a great term such a great
piece it's not putting any pressure on
b5 for example this is all fairly normal
now Quincy to we should be seven but
should be 2 plus 9 27 by the way I'm
quite curious that they both played this
so quickly as this is a very unusual
line they're basically no games in the
database of this so I'm interesting they
played really quickly yeah maybe also
they both wanted to get this over with
and sometimes happens you're in the last
round then both the players really know
it's a rotten tournament but you don't
want to draw and then you just play some
quick moves and suddenly you in some
fight so quite interesting what's
happening here be 3c three yeah if black
would have taken here then one idea is
not be 3 to control the c5 square make
sure that this Bishop is not activated
in fact this is the whole theme now of
the game that
Bishop on this heaven isn't great and
would like to play c5 in the game c3 was
played tonight before and then aged 6
yeah nakamura know it took on no she
played this sorry I confused the Nevada
we should page for London g5 was played
here white could play Bishop g3 or take
first he took for us I think also this
is a better than Bishop d3 but the the
position you need to look at them is
here here Milosevic played very
interesting move he's got more than one
possible continuation but he just played
them I think the the most interesting
that also addresses the main problem of
blacks position perfectly he played c5
immediately opening up this Bishop and
this is a strong piece now not being
incarcerated behind the porn on c6 it's
also returning upon yet knock i took the
pawn also probably the best simply get
this back which would be four of this
Bishop is immediately active now we need
to Antioch CA so it's equal material and
black hopes that this pawn is an
important asset while white hopes that
this is a weakness both are true and
let's see what what happens pusher
basics took on d4 and I take say of
course if white is take here this is
this coming and you don't want to see
that as white so 90 form and look to see
five
this is a flexible news group d 52
covering the fifth-ranked rope t1 plate
and here i think down maybe morale is
making a mistake and it's also i'm the
computers access mode assessment is
playing 95 now and this seems to lead to
some trouble for black something like
Queen B 6 was probably sounder 95 has
got a problem and the problem is that
after night see to this is threatened
black doesn't really have a great reply
can also take but this is certainly
something as something somewhat better
for wide he played Queen to be success
this is the normal natural-looking move
and here right um should have taken the
chance to play Bishop d3 and I'm quite
surprised that he didn't do that because
after taking the ideas like h4 Bishop g5
v for really enough dangerous for black
and I think black he needs to be very
precise to not being wiped out this can
get to a very dangerous initiative
quickly let's say like moves us just for
argument's sake when there's H form
which is dangerous or queen age six
which is maybe even better how does he
defend this now that's also efore and
rook lift Bishop d3 was was a chance for
white I think he has some a after that
Bishop c4 was instead plate and then
whoop Dee for this was the idea probably
we should back and age for so we have a
really really unclear position and
complicated position anything can happen
you just retreated here takes
and rook g4 of course the camera is
hiding for witness always it will get
very sharp soon now if all this is all
all ok why does not play any bad move
take stakes and e5 now Queen g7 so here
white um it seems should play knight to
e 1 intending 93 queener 3 something
like that pick up their pawn it's
probably Andrew it's really an unclear
position i mean i know that unclear and
the the edge of the computer is a very
unpopular assessment because everybody
can easily switch on an engine and get
some some assessment but in a game
between human players of about equal
strength this is really a position that
can go anybody's way it's so complicated
Lex chances now on the edge for
something like that well wyd maybe also
has chances him there's also the sea
porn it's just very complicated this was
played however and now black gets a big
big initiative probably the size of one
loop h8 g3 and who page six now black is
doubling on the edge fun
yep black can open up the position and
use his rooks very nicely here why this
is already lost you cannot defend this
anymore he played Quincy 6 and after the
trade Bishop c5 this was some the
business was reached black sir trump
cards are the bishops the seaport and
whites wicking everything together makes
it a winning position head whoopsie 12
to cover the night but after look here
this was text 93 and Bishop d4 just
simple strong play this pawn is
protected this one is attacked and what
is wyd supposed to play there is nothing
kleber should be fired and now black
took it simply grabbing the pawn 91 and
look before attending to get here if
what now takes it didn't do that if what
it takes there's this hanging of course
so he took on g6 not a move you would
like to play but where exactly is this
loop going let's say you go here for
argument's sake
also not great yeah white is really
busted naw Kham took on g6 at the end
and grabs III but this is the end of the
day it's just an exchange and the next
report a couple of more moves but then
there's really not not much happening
it's just a very simple technical task
NTN a camera resigned so we really
managed to lose all three final games of
this tournament plummeting down from the
top of the leaderboard to to fifty
percent what if what could have been an
excellent tournament video and the
disastrously with 3m losses at the end
and with two whites on top of it yeah
not quite sure what Nakamura is doing
sometimes so how to how to to analyze
without knowing any any inside
information it's it's strange though
he's playing x absolutely great in the
middle of the tournament and then it's
just a disaster at the end okay so now
let's have a look at the fight for the
final standings start with chrome neck
against Gelfond we have a symmetrical
English and chrome dick playing 93 and
in some way Knight c3 already signals
alright I'm not playing for so much
today in some way it does it does that
on this level usually if they want to
push and there's not f3 with a quick d
for coming on it's just a bit sharpen
Knight c3 the main problem with this is
to move g6 and this is what girl phone
is playing after this we get the
symmetrical position where it's rather
difficult for y to make any headway
especially after Knight f3 which is the
main move Black has a couple of very
solid continuations that
White has really a hard time to prove
any advantage against the e6 is Fisher
smooth very solid that is d 6 e 5 even
Knight f6 is okay a complete symmetry so
it's a very solid already for black but
what chrome deck is playing now is
really a move that sighs okay let's draw
III is a very very solid but very very
dry simply because black can do exactly
the same in six ninety to ninety seven
castles castles d4 takes takes of dips
everything's taken here white even could
take d5 but it's um this line is really
a complete dead wrong with no one
nothing else possible black is quickly
attacking the pawn and we even have some
slight imbalance here or four pieces but
this is still just the wrong white
really doesn't have any substantial plan
here to to get forward yeah this some
even exchanges those two it's it's just
them completely dull line after this
here they agree to draw after this
smooth sequence obviously kind of a non
game but it's it's quite understandable
in government knows that with the draw
his hain he has secured shout at least
shared first place as Calvin can only
catch up to him with a win with black
against me with Yara which isn't easy to
do and um galfond this is not winning
against Kramnik with black am anyway
normally
so Gavin solid approach is
understandable and chronic simply wants
to get it over with this tournament I
guess um this also means if you look at
moral he want the game that Kramnik is
the really this is the bottom end of the
table he's he lost three games didn't
win any and is the sole um last place in
this field and governed is secured
shared first with with the drop let's
look at the final game Mammadyarov
against Carlton Carlton has black he
needs to win to catch up with girlfriend
and let's see what he what he tried to
do alright so g6 we get a king's indian
so bit of a fighting hoping nvidia of
place g 38 d really doesn't play that
too often he really prefers more more
central approach but okay this is a
really good line c6 and Bishop f5
interesting cars and plays this before
castles this idea the idea is that black
wants to exchange one pair of minor
pieces and after this which is very
often played black has quite solid
position a good bishop p.m. and black
can even sometimes played e5 e6 and take
their to set up a very healthy position
without pants on light squares and upon
the bishop on which is heaven this is
rather solid set up but Maria of played
differently didn't intake played this
one which is quite good the idea is to
play maybe night h4 later and in general
to push if all the defect after all that
Carlton takes on c3 and now the look is
here exactly right to get a fine here in
this position um
a couple of moves have been tried causal
plays a rare one is playing Queen to c8
it seems that the most popular and
probably best move is the somewhat
paradoxical bishop to c 8 it is rather
strange i know i'm developing but black
guy really needs to get some
coordination for his pieces in and the
bishop is not helping so much on f5 or
black for instance likes to do is
something like this night here here and
d5 and the bishop simply gets out of the
way and protect flip on this is the most
popular move that also gives black
fairly decent results cars not ever
played Queen to see 8 which isn't
necessarily terrible but the other movie
sir is maybe somewhat better well let's
continue eform occupying the center and
e5 so what is pushing quickly to make
sure that the position opens up and he
makes use of his space advantage this
way he took him and played details e5
and now mamedyarov is playing this very
nicely he doesn't recapture on on e5 he
just plays would be one and this is just
stronger than any capture because b7 is
threatened here
Carlton also had the opportunity and
actually prefer this move to play b6
it's not particularly attractive move
I'm sure and maybe I know but then I
still think you should have done that
after Bishop e3 Quincy 7 this position
is certainly a compensation for white
but how much this isn't so clear white
has long has probably enough but does he
have an edge even I don't know very
strong bishops this was played in the
game and I have to take stakes white not
took on Bishop muches perfectly all
right he gets the pawn back he's still
up or down but he gets one back and of
course why does some excellently
positioned here with the both rooks we
should afford the bishop here so it's a
very good active position neck really
needs to be cautious here it seems that
still counts had a good continuation
here he played twin to f5 which at the
end seems to fail he could have played
Knight to d7 and this is a much better
yeah play gets very complicated now I
only had the time for um rather brief
computer-supported analysis and this
analysis seemed to be okay for black but
i'm pretty sure that investing more time
so probably rewarding in this position
it's very complicated one line that is
important the screen here Knight e5 and
then the point is if white takes here
black has got the very strong moves
Queen to f5 and this in fact secures the
draw after some funny lines with rupee
starting here and now King King in the
corner yeah this is in fact a draw who
like you can analyze them sidelines
yourself yet but this is too strong a
threat it's not working immediately by
the way okay yes this check so black
here needs to take first now this is
threatened and Queen h3y term needs to
force the draw with Bishop to be too and
then after it takes tanks and five black
has fine position still Queen h3 is the
issue if you play something like this
this tester this one this is one of many
checkmates so probably this isn't too
great to take him on it what can take
first here
yeah this is some the line after 97 and
after Bishop to e3 its material equality
but the White has got the sea porn I
believe that black has good chances to
hold but it's am not easy to play as
well in the game he played Queen f5
immediately and this is some the problem
97 is just the relatively best move here
this is what Carson plate and this
actually it's not working at all we are
off plate kingi too but here white had
the very strong move Bishop to be to
just a tactical idea after Bishop takes
there's Queen head and why does an
exchange up I totally see any comp that
there's nothing that black and black can
do so it's very well known that V she is
such an excellent I'm sorry fishy we
have confusing this also that cards in a
second such an excellent defender but I
don't really see what what black should
have in this position like this you can
just take here it's probably just the
exchange so big chance here from
mamedyarov what he played he played King
g2 also keeps a pretty pretty decent
edge but it's not as decisive 9 a-6 you
need to go somewhere it's not hanging
here under 95 attacking the Queen which
took on e seven there also was the move
Queen to c6 that also gives white a
pretty big edge for example something
like this it's just excellent for white
this is the target both these pawns of
targets especially seven plus the
bishops and so on and so on it's really
ugly so this was another good
opportunity but he took him 93 and
rookie form and it seems that instead of
this rook move maybe Bishop f8 or look
to you one was a bit bit more testing
but white has spots some of the edge
already and after rookie for there was
Bishop g7 plate which wasn't the best
195 was somewhat stronger and this I
think secures black a good play I mean
good play wrong word and a draw probably
by some sort of repetition a possible
line is this loop here Queen takes rook
takes Knight takes and this now the big
made threat but
okay yeah this is a draw perpetual if
white tries to win even there's this one
and black wins yeah Bishop g7 and
step-offs plate set off 95 and here I
think why it still keeps some edge but
it's not clear that this is really
enough to win again you get the same
game now with opposite colored bishops
but it's not a pure bishop and game with
looks on the board this opposite color
factors isn't so so big it is there but
it's not the decisive issue in fact in
the game after Luke a 548 Carlton got
some counter play here quickly going on
this if white no takes a seven there's
this one oh he even he even took their
sorry rogue f2 isn't though it's not bad
as well he played Bishop before though
it's a quite quite similar sorry quite
similar Kingair sri and Bishop b5 yeah
it's one pawn but the opposite colored
bishops in fact after whoop t5 Bishop to
see seven would be seven here a draw was
a grid um which I've found slightly
surprising to be honest because let's
say here it's not clear I can also look
at this why not a form I mean it I
understand that black has good chances
to draw because this is not not playing
this is an active rook but it's I don't
know it's still upon why not try on a
bit not sure why morale from
agreed to a draw and the drawing chances
for black for Carlton are really good
but yeah because you could could have
tried a bit more all right maybe he was
disappointed because of the missed
opportunities earlier so let's do a
quick roundup of the whole event the big
winner is surprisingly galfond who
always has been an excellent player but
he rarely wins those kind of events he
is the guy who makes an excellent third
place winning a couple of rating points
not losing a game only losing one game
but he's rarely wins the events and Here
I am probably played the best chess of
his career in terms of a round-robin
tournament did not look at the candidate
some in 2011 for example he also played
excellent chess and he really am Scott
very fine wins without being in trouble
his excellent preparation helps a lot
and and always keep in mind he's 44
years old and this is simply amazing to
play the best chess of your career in
this rather advanced age in chess terms
and he had the main shocker certainly
Kramnik being lost he seems to be I
don't know out of out of shape after the
candidates maybe he put in so much
effort into this tournament that after
that there's some lack of energy I mean
it's already two month after that more
than two month but still that's probably
like illogically very difficult to to
play after that I don't know thousand a
second place I guess he won't be too
excited about his result but it wasn't
bad at all I mean he am basically I'm
played on the level of his rating maybe
maybe losing one or two points nothing
nothing dramatic he will play before the
world championship match
in the sink fields cap in in the US and
San Luis the first top-level chess event
in the US for ages and together with
Nakamura of course who's the local local
hero very strong tournament in the US
and I want I think already announced
that he won't play a game until the
world championship match and concentrate
on on preparation yeah what cousin
certainly can need to suddenly will
appreciate is that he won the games he
won he won very nicely he beat Nakamura
when it counted he beat Anand the world
champion very good for the for the
upcoming match and he also beat kramnik
is also very important if you think back
to the candidates it was a between those
two nte mention managed to beat him
alright thanks for watching the video
hope you enjoyed the coverage are from
this tournament I'm not quite sure what
coverage i'll be doing next this thing
filled cup in the u.s. is is one one
possibility the only slight issue with
this is maybe the the time difference so
I'm not quite sure when I'll be able to
do any recaps let's see what what
happens yeah thanks for watching and
I'll be back soon